[Music]
and make no mistake my lady the dead are
coming is this true
your uncle fought them at the fist of
the first men I for the net hardhome
we're both lost what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season eight and game theory
video what I am about to present to you
today is something that is very
different than anything I have ever made
before this just might be the craziest
theory I have ever heard and I know some
people probably won't believe it or even
be able to fully understand it but if
you pay very close attention it will
make sense in the end first I will play
you a series of clips from a few
different episodes and at first they
probably won't make much sense because
they don't seem to have any connection
but in the end it will all come together
and once you realize what it is it will
be undeniable so buckle your seat belts
and prepare to have your mind blown
does she truly want to be Noah
yes I'm not playing this stupid game
anymore
we never stop playing oh my sweet summer
child what do you know about fear fear
is for the winter when the snows fall a
hundred feet deep fear is for the long
night when the Sun hides for years and
children are born and live and die all
in darkness the many-faced God taught
him how to shed his face and how to give
the gift the mentored others in exchange
for this earth many served many more
gifts were given soon all the Masters in
overseers were gone the faceless men
fled why did they go no there's another
kill him he turned them all
you don't understand why are you crying
[Music]
he was my friend
he wasn't didn't you listen to him he
was no one winter has come
if the maesters are right it'll be the
coldest one in a thousand years we
should ride home and wait out the coming
storms the war is not over and I promise
you friend the true enemy won't wait out
the storm
he brings the storm better go keeps
secrets but does not for a man to spoil
them
you wanted them now
I should have let you burn
your grace if my father had seen the
things that I've seen he'd also tell you
to burn the dead before nightfall all of
them
you said you'd teach me how to be a
faceless man a man teaches a girl well I
do iris opening must serve faceless men
most of all you made the White Walkers
we're at war
we're being slaughtered our sacred trees
cut down we need you to defend ourselves
from her from you my dad see mass was
from Braavos the beer dancing masters a
special thing but to be a faceless man
that is something else entirely the girl
has many names on her lips Joffrey
Cersei Tywin Lannister Ilyn Payne the
out name stuff up to the red God don't
bring me back
I'll have to try I'm ordering you not to
bring me back I am NOT your servant once
you're in my camp I'm the commander I
served the Lord of Light I do what he
wants
how do you know where he commands it's a
choice although I walk with White
Walkers have been gone for thousands of
years he was like
[Music]
and that man sees what he sees re now
let me jump in here for a minute and
just remind you to pay very close
attention to these next few clips
because this will help everything make
sense all the scenes you just watch were
some very subtle foreshadowing for how
the series will end but these upcoming
scenes are arguably the most important
in the entire series thus far this is
about to reveal Jack and agar in the
night Kings true plan and motives listen
very carefully to every word that is
said and keep an eye on the characters
facial expressions because they are very
telling Jack McGaw
a girl gives a man his own name that's
right
gods are not mocked there is no jerking
thing I'm not joking
man can go kill himself unnamed me if
the Lord was done with me so be it but
he's not you've seen the night King Jon
Snow
you know the Great War still to come you
know the army of the Dead will be upon
us soon and you know I can help you win
their war anyway I know you will find
his way to the world and when he does
you will be there waiting for him and he
will be ready
[Music]
bigger less work to do
[Music]
she's not ready
perhaps J's perhaps she's not and if
she's not it is all the same to the
many-faced God
we need to get back to the wall
it's a long march you know it's out
there
we have to make it have to warn them or
before winters done everyone you've ever
known will be dead in the ancient books
it's written that a warrior will draw a
burning sword from the fire
and that sword shall be Lightbringer
sorry
so something say that job
whatever it was I daresay you'll see it
again if a girl is truly Noah she has
nothing to fear the long night is coming
and the dead come with it now clan can
stop them the free folk can't stop them
the Nights Watch can't stop them and all
the southern Kings can't stop them
yourself does she truly want to be no.1
yes I'm not playing its stupid game
anymore we never stop playing I'm not
playing this stupid game anymore
we never stop playing I'm not playing
this stupid game anymore
we never stop playing I'm not playing
this stupid game anymore we're never
stop play
[Music]
[Music]